los desafíos logísticos son enormes son
nueve etapas la de hoy es la primera que
arrancó con personas que están sobre los
80 años espera que sobre navidad las
personas que están en ancianatos y sus
cuidadores se empiecen a recibir estas
vacunas como dices si en los hospitales
hay mucho optimismo pero también hay que
ser muy precavidos porque todavía el
coach sigue siendo una amenaza para la
humanidad y por ello el gobierno ha
pedido que si hay que celebrar este
momento histórico para la ciencia pero
hay que tener mucho cuidado
especialmente ahora que las temperaturas
ya sean muy bajas las personas están
optimistas en el hospital hay zonas
especiales para poner estas vacunas y se
espera que posteriormente pueda ser
llevado a otras zonas porque como decía
la complejidad de transportarla viene
desde bélgica pero debe estar almacenada
en condiciones especiales que sólo
tienen los hospitales hay una noticia de
última hora es bien importante también
en este día y es que oxford y
astrazéneca han dicho que la vacuna que
están desarrollando es segura y efectiva
y podría incluso reducir los índices de
transmisión esta es otra gran noticia
que llega hoy en la lucha contra el cob
it
bien es importante resaltar que el
segundo paciente en coventry que recibió
la vacuna contra el kobe es william
shakespeare de 81 años de la misma zona
del genial dramaturgo británico y llama
la atención y vale la pena preguntarse
que hubiera escrito william shakespeare
el genial william shakespeare sobre esta
pandemia que azota el mundo